internet célèbre ses 50 ans alors qu'en
1969 on réussissait pour la première
fois à relier deux ordinateurs
d'universités américaines en 2018 la
proportion de canadiens âgés de 15 ans
et plus qui ont utilisé internet s'est
élevé à 91 %
mélanie millette et professeur au
département de communication sociale et
publique à l'uqam mélanie millette
bonsoir on va regarder un peu les
données de statistique canada qui a
publié une enquête aujourd'hui très
intéressante sur l'utilisation
d'internet et tout de suite on y va avec
les premiers chiffres où on voit
l'utilisation d'internet selon le groupe
d'âge les plus jeunes sont à 98 temps à
98% à 45 64 à 93% et les 65 ans et plus
71 pour ça que nous disent ces chiffres
déjà ça nous dit que les usages internet
c'est vraiment presque universel
maintenant on est vraiment dans des
proportions extrêmement près de 100 % de
la totalité des gens même la france j'ai
65 ans et plus une progression
extrêmement intéressante par rapport aux
résultats des années antérieures 7
explique de différentes façons d'une
part les personnes de 65 ans et plus
sont par exemple aujourd'hui les baby
boomers qui est tranquillement arrive à
cet âge là et qui sont souvent des
personnes qui ont utilisé l'ordinateur
pendant la plus grande partie de leur
vie active de travailleurs travailleuses
donc ça fait des personnes qui sont
beaucoup plus enclines à utiliser les
technologies donc à persister dans leur
usage
d'autre part il ya une facilitation de
l'accès à ces différentes technologies
le par exemple avec la tablette
auparavant pour se familiariser avec
l'internet fallait utiliser l'ordinateur
mais si vous êtes une personne qui n'est
pas du tout confortable pas du tout
technophiles la tablette -un la liseuse
par exemple c'est un très bonne porte
d'entrée maintenant pour se familiariser
comme personne plus âgée qui n'a pas
nécessairement
les deux grandes connaissances
techniques et les applications ont
changé aujourd'hui on choisit des
applications c'est des petits carrés
s'est rendue facile d'utiliser c'est
beaucoup moins abstrait qu'avant donc
même chose en maintenant avec les
technologies mobiles comme les
téléphones et la tablette on voit son
application c'est une petite icône
isoler toute seule
on sait ce qu'elle fait en plus sur les
tablettes c'est une navigation par
application une à la fois le plus
souvent donc c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'organiser sa pensée dans cet univers
là que sur un ordinateur de table
portable mais ces technologies aussi se
sont se sont améliorées aux thermes de
luz habilité autres données tirées de
statistique canada il ya le bon côté des
choses dont on vient de parler
l'accès mais il ya toute la question de
la sécurité bien sûr statistique canada
demander aux gens s'ils avaient eu des
incidents liés à la sécurité sur
internet 57 % parle d'incidents de cyber
sécurité vécu sur internet 48% disent
avoir reçu des courriels ou d'autres
messages frauduleux 18 7 % disent avoir
été redirigés vers des sites frauduleux
et il ya d'autres catégories comme ça de
gens qui disent avoir vécu des incidents
liés à la sécurité
il ya différentes choses à avoir lancé
steve cclat premièrement ce sont des
statistiques pour 2018 l'année 2018
c'est a commencé avec le scandale
facebook et qu'un but john à l'éthique à
faut garder ça en tête on en a beaucoup
parlé dans différents médias dans
différents plateaux nous expliquer
pourquoi c'était un problème qu'est ce
qui se passe avec les données comment
faire pour augmenter notre propre
sécurité comme utilisateur de la triste
de l'internet
donc je pense que ça porte fruit d'une
part et on reconnaît davantage d'autre
part ce type d'incident frauduleux ou
une problématique et on les déclare puce
on est également un peu mieux outillés
je l'espère en tout cas même si ça reste
abstrait quand on parle de données
d'infrastructures bon d'infonuagique ça
reste abstrait pour la plupart des gens
mais de nos jours les pratiques par
exemple par rapport aux codes de
sécurité ou
on est tout seul on a de bien meilleures
pratiques on les change régulièrement on
met des n'est plus compliquée par
rapport aux gars également ses
paramètres de sécurité maintenant c'est
monnaie courante csu j'espère en tout
cas qu'il faut resserrer nos paramètres
de sécurité notamment dans facebook une
des principales failles dans facebook
c'est la fonction amis d'amis donc quand
on publie et que notre publication les
soient publiques soient ouvertes à tous
les amis de nos amis c'est souvent par
là qu'on prête flanc à des dérives ya
des problèmes qui me donne a dit que
c'était comme ça que ça fonctionnait
pour récolter des données en fait très
intéressant autre graphique tirer aussi
de statistique canada ce sont les titres
de services et de technologies liens
internet 93,6 % des gens disent avoir
accès à internet à partir de la maison
pente hausse de 91 % utilisent et près
de 94
on accède donc il y en a qui ont accès à
la maison mais qu'il utilise pas
nécessairement on va les commentaires un
peu 84% au magazine en ligne
oui c'est très très documenté en fait on
a longtemps été très enclin enquête à
utiliser internet pour se documenter en
comparer par exemple les prix pour un
produit comparé les commentaires que les
autres utilisateurs ont laissé sur un
produit mais on était plus plus
réfractaires à acheter en alors que ans
ici on voit c'est quelque chose qui
augmente et je suis notamment les
chercher mon sens et des données
canadiennes
mais pour le québec pour la même année
donc selon le site riom 2018 il s'est
dépensé 10 points 5 milliards de dollars
ce qui était une hausse de 27% par
rapport à l'année 2010 est donc ses
chansons et de plusieurs confortable
donc moi je mettrais sans lien avec la
donne les données précédentes par
rapport à la cyber sécurité
on est conscient que ça existe on essaie
de mieux s'outiller on en parle
davantage pour expliquer comment faire
donc on sait maintenant comment
reconnaître un site sécurisé comment
faire un achat de manière sécurisée 82 %
des gens disent à des comptes de réseaux
sociaux 74% ont utilisé des services
gouvernementaux en ligne
69 % à utiliser ou acheter des services
de vidéo en continu
oui un mois il ya clairement un lien à
faire avec avec toute la discussion
politique qui est importante en ce
moment par rapport aux redevances et aux
taxes qui sont 2
moyen différent de perception pour
récupérer d argent qui partent
finalement du québec et du canada pour
aller dans les poches principalement le
des géants d'internet lagat femmes
google amazon facebook et microsoft et
aussi d'autres services comme spotify
qui suit doit donc je pense qu'il ya une
urgence de légiférer ce moment là parce
qu'on le voit 68 points à 8 %
c'est plus du tout une tendance qui est
minoritaire ce n'est plus du tout un
phénomène a balayé du revers de la main
en disant ce sont les jeunes emilio
emini lario donc ça devient quelque
chose de très très prégnant il faut s'en
occuper et encadré c'est intéressant la
suite et bien sûr et sur le site de
statistique canada mais la ligne est
merci beaucoup pour ses explications ce
soir